♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
The White House announced over
the weekend that a third batch
of classified documents
was found
at President Biden's
Delaware home.
You know, finding new ones
every few days isn't helping.
What are you guys
doing over there?
Searching one drawer at a time?
Did he hide the documents
in an advent calendar?
[ Laughter ]
That's right, a third batch of
classified documents was found
at President Biden's
Delaware home
in a room next
to his garage.
Man, is there a more Biden
hiding place than the room
next to the garage?
Just telling neighbors, "Yeah,
sure, you can borrow
the weed whacker. It's in
the room next to the garage."
If you hit the nuclear codes,
you've gone too far.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden visited Ebenezer
Baptist church in Atlanta
yesterday to honor
Martin Luther King Jr..
Became the first sitting
President to deliver
a Sunday sermon.
And I'll tell you what,
when he was done,
there was not an open eye
in the house.
[ Laughter ]
After the FAA last week
temporarily grounded
all domestic flight departures
due to a computer outage,
it's been reported
that the software responsible
is years away from
a potential update.
Really? Because I feel like if
you just put Apple in charge,
they'll update it
every three months.
[ Laughter ]
New York mayor Eric Adams
yesterday visited El Paso,
Texas, to tour immigration
facilities and meet
with local officials.
Dude, you're the mayor
of New York.
Why are you wandering all over
the country like a dad at Sears?
"I'm going to go look
at the tires."
"Dad, we're here
for my school supplies."
[ Laughter ]
Lottery officials have announced
that the Mega Millions
$1.35 billion jackpot was won by
a single ticket holder in Maine.
And if you're wondering what
they're going to buy with that,
Maine.
[ Laughter ]
The national weather service has
warned that a recent drop
in temperatures in Florida could
cause iguanas to enter
a dormant state and fall out of
trees, which has left residents
of Florida scrambling
for recipes.
[ Laughter ]
"Mom, what's in the pasta?"
The Dallas Zoo was closed
on Friday
until a 4-year-old
clouded leopard named Nova
was returned to her habitat.
Oh, you mean the jungle?
[ Laughter ]
News flash -- no leopard's
habitat is Dallas.
Leopard print, sure,
but not leopard.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
Italy's most wanted man,
an alleged organized crime boss,
Matteo Messina Denaro,
was arrested today
after 30 years on the run.
He's expected to serve
at least two life sentences,
plus five years consulting
on an HBO series
about his life.
♪♪
President Biden hosted the NBA
champion Golden State Warriors
today at the White House,
where they gave him
an honorary jersey,
and he gave them the location
of Israel's nukes.
"Oh, wait, hold on.
I'm gonna need those back."
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that it does not keep
visitor logs
for President Biden's personal
residence in Delaware.
If you want to know who visited,
you'll just have to watch
"Jay Leno's Garage."
[As Leno] Eh, I think these are
classified documents.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
Thank you, it was very...
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Alabama and Mississippi
yesterday observed
a state holiday that honors
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
and Confederate general
Robert E. Lee.
I'm sorry, did I say "and"?
Because I definitely meant "or."
[ Laughter ]
"I like 'em both!"
In a new episode of a podcast,
former President Trump said
that he heard Florida governor
Ron DeSantis may challenge him
for the Republican presidential
nomination, and added, quote,
"We'll handle that
the way I handle things."
So get ready, Ron --
he's gonna cheat on you.
[ Laughter ]
That's how he do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When asked in a new interview
about Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell,
Louisiana Senator John Kennedy
said that McConnell
is an enigma,
and added that he, quote, "saw
him smile once back in 2017."
Said McConnell, "I remember it.
It was at the end
of 'Marley & Me.'"
[ Laughter ]
[As McConnell]
That was very, uh...
That Marley finally got
what was coming to him.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cackles as McConnell ]
[Normal voice]
Prince William visited
the charity Together As One
today for a cooking lesson
and shared his favorite
cake recipe --
"tell someone
to make you a cake."
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
Missouri DMV officials recently
released a list
of the 500 vanity license plates
that were rejected last year,
including one that read "GOTAZZ"
on the grounds
of false advertising.
[ Laughter ]
The only reason I picked
that joke today --
the writers also describe what
they want in the key over here,
and the writer wrote,
"A man with a flat ass,
shot in profile."
And I was curious if it would be
clear that he'd got no "azz,"
and, uh...
totally is.
[ Laughter ]
Today was talk show host
Maury Povich's 84th birthday,
so pretty safe to say
he's not the father.
[ Laughter ]
That joke has a flat ass.
And finally, according
to a new report,
three NFL teams are considering
pursuing quarterback Tom Brady
when he becomes a free agent,
not to mention about
a dozen bocci leagues.
♪♪
According to a new poll,
President Biden would defeat
former president Trump
in a hypothetical 2024
election rematch by 8 points.
Pretty bad,
but not as defeated as I feel
hearing about that poll.
Can we not do this yet?
[ Laughter ]
It's January.
The only thing I want to hear
less than a presidential poll
is a Christmas carol.
[ Laughter ]
Secretary of State Tony Blinken
sent a cable to all embassies
yesterday
directing staff to switch from
Times New Roman font to Calibri,
while President Biden will
continue to speak in Wingdings.
[ Laughter ]
Georgia congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
was assigned yesterday
to the House Committee
on Homeland Security.
Well, she does seem
to know about attacks
before they happen.
[ Laughter ]
The Treasury Department
said that tomorrow,
it will begin using
extraordinary measures
to keep the federal government
running,
which explains
this new eBay listing.
[ Laughter ]
I think they made a terrible
mistake adding free shipping.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
Republican congressman
George Santos
allegedly stole $3,000
from a GoFundMe campaign
for a dying service dog that
belonged to a disabled veteran,
and then get this, he used
the money to buy dog poison.
[ Audience groans ]
Now, again,
halfway through that joke,
I started thinking, "How do I
think this is going to go?"
[ Laughter ]
It's a bad joke,
but is it as bad...
as what he did?
[ Laughter ]
Still seems like you guys
might think it's a tie.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like
I'm Congress material.
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department
this week confirmed --
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department this week
confirmed a new set of policies
that incentivizes companies
to report wrongdoing
in exchange for
deferred prosecution,
which could prevent us
from seeing
over a dozen new limited series.
[ Laughter ]
Should we unplug it
and plug it back in?
[ Laughter ]
A boy in Maine recently
broke a Guinness world record
by building a nearly
12,000-piece LEGO set
in just over nine hours, much
to the chagrin of his parents.
"That was supposed to
take you all year!"
[ Laughter ]
New York's Port Authority
announced yesterday
that it will close
the New Jersey-bound tube
of the Holland Tunnel next month
for construction.
So if you need to go
to New Jersey,
I have even more bad news.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Washington State
are looking for a man
who allegedly tried
to kidnap a barista
by pulling them through
the drive-through window.
Despite the best efforts
of police,
the suspect remains at venti.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I stand by it.
Today was
National Thesaurus Day.
It was, yeah, good.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the world's oldest
known person, a French nun,
has reportedly died
at the age of 118.
And I got to say,
I'd feel pretty bad
if I was the one who bought her
that skateboard.
[ Laughter ]
What happened to us?
Well, to be fair,
this is only our fourth show.
1,389?
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
Now you're going to tell me
it's bad luck
to make fun
of a dead French nun.
[ Laughter ]
Is that her?
Why did we have to
put her picture up?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, good.
Look, I don't want
to blame this on you guys.
You've done nothing wrong.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
President Biden, on Tuesday,
ordered lunch from
the Washington restaurant
Ghostburger
and got a burger with bacon.
Wow.
First, the classified documents.
Now bacon burgers.
It's like Trump never left.
I mean, what is
Biden going to do next?
Oh, no!
In a series of posts yesterday
on Truth Social,
former president Trump
pushed back against claims
that he illegally stored
classified files at Mar-a-Lago
and accused federal agents
of planting documents
inside of empty folders
he had taken.
Oh, you are trying anything.
That's like telling the police,
"Someone else
put the cocaine there.
I just collect
tiny plastic baggies."
Looks like Trump
has upped his game
to try and win back the title of
Most Hilarious Liar.
The first anti-abortion
March for Life rally
is set to take place tomorrow
in Washington, D.C.,
since the Supreme Court
overturned Roe vs. Wade.
Though I'm not sure
their updated chants
have the same impact.
"What do we want?"
"Roe overturned."
"When do we get it?"
"Last year."
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department
announced the arrest of
the Russian founder of
a cryptocurrency exchange
in Miami this week on charges of
laundering over $700 million.
The DOJ first became suspicious
when he was a Russian in Miami.
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
criticized the NHL last week
for plans to hold
a hiring event aimed at
diversifying the
league's workforce.
Imagine how racist
you have to be
to think that hockey isn't
white enough.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rapper -- This is exciting news.
Rapper Snoop Dogg
is set to be inducted into
the Songwriters Hall of Fame,
which is the songwriting
profession's highest person.
According to the latest numbers,
there are 1,400 stores
in New York that are
illegally selling marijuana
and at least 1,400 other stores
that are deeply grateful
for that.
The Senate Judiciary Committee
has announced
that it will hold a hearing
next week on
Ticketmaster's mishandling
of Taylor Swift's ticket sales,
and even that's sold out.
According to a new study,
men who take Viagra
decrease their risk of
developing heart disease
by nearly 40%.
So even more bad news
for exhausted grandmas.
He's going to be around
for a while.
And, finally,
health officials in Canada
released new guidelines
this week
that say no amount of alcohol
is healthy.
But take that with
a grain of salt
and a wedge of lime.
That was a monologue,
everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]